women are like packed animals and if you
get the wrong group of women the wrong
chick in her ear women just kind of go
left and the point that Myron is making
is that why would you put a girl in a
situation that is going to compromise
your relationship like why would you
allow a woman to constantly put herself
in situations that compromise her
relationships there's nothing wrong with
getting to know her friends but if her
friends want to go to the club all of
the time what does that say about her
and I think a wise woman limits you know
the type of friends she brings around
and the friends understand that you're
not going to move the same way in a
relationship that you would single